our schooling came within the live work
that presented itself then we naturally
got better so as more opportunities came
all right well I'm going to embrace this
I'm going to knock it out but you became
a well oil machine because you got reps
practice I can cry on a spot can you yes
I I on a
spot let me see want to do it let me see
you want to see it yeah all right better
buckle up let me see here it
comes
you you look like they have the air on
you look like you're like a seizure no
okay is this look like a seizure are you
ready for
this now you look constipated no no no
cuz you didn't let me finish okay
finish I don't want to do it listen what
what I do want well anyways I don't
didn't think I knew how to do it you can
do it and on I know now that I can do it
you did cuz you put yourself in a
situation you put yourself in a
situation you're going to cry because
you're acting I'm not a crier person I
am a little bit weird like I I don't cry
that
much I am yes yeah I and and I I was
very we very very worried that I was not
going to be able to cry can I give you a
true story like seriously I'm joking
around about playing like oh yeah I can
cry I'm just joking now because you
can't cry well I'm going to give you can
you listen to my story but can
you cry or not cry I'm about to
tell you okay tell me okay go ahead go
okay I'm trying okay all right so we did
the um this movie fatherhood right and
fatherhood um story about me with this
little girl father who had to overcome
trials and tribulations of taking on the
responsibility of fatherhood while not
having the means to do it okay my wife
died of delivery and oh my God my life
right and the first scene I'm with
Alfrey Woodard and uh this is like day
12 of the movie maybe and the whole
shoot I'm thinking about this day
because of Alfrey Woodard and I'm like I
know where she's coming in at and I need
to make sure on this day I'm prepared I
really I just I didn't know and I said
if I don't get lost in the scene I'm not
going to be able to pull it off and on
the day on the actual day um I
told the director I said can you start
off close and we get it and then as we
get wide we know that we got it because
I don't know how many times I'm going to
be able to get it yeah and I said I have
to get lost in the world of what alrey
does yeah because I know how she's going
to come in and I really waited to see
what Alfy's performance was and in the
scene Alfy's performance made me
cry all of my tears came from
she did her reaction to Da dying is what
made me as the husband cry cuz I was in
the hallway trying to be strong and so
the mother presented herself yeah but
those are things like for example don't
you think that they teach them in acting
class you know we don't know those
things so we had to find a so it's like
crazy super scar you're chii cheich she
like in other words that's what I use I
didn't want to say that I didn't want to
voice that but I was like you didn't
want cheat sheet oh cheat sheet don't
but don't I didn't say it like
that I saw you said cheat no cheat sheet
okay that's that's how I cheated God
damn it you want me to say it I
cheated Sophia I mean that's what she's
trying to get me to say that I cheated
you think you're slick she wants me to
say I cheated fine I
cheated
a